humans are what we are we learn
partially when we learned from other
people through essentially empathy
through emulation you know monkey see
monkey do we can learn many things
through imitation but ultimately like
the imitation has to be appropriate to
our time and it has to be this
independent spark of creativity where we
apply a principle that we learn from a
concrete example to a different concrete
example it's one thing to say well you
know knowledge was preserved in the
monasteries of the Roman Empire or
Confucius successfully selected and
employed his students he taught his
students so that they could be advisors
of ministers of state even if he himself
could never be a minister of state at
least not very good one at least he
couldn't win at the local politics of it
even if he could win at knowledge these
are two concrete examples but what's the
generalization the generalization
derived from this is that society needs
islands and reserves of knowledge a
society loses the knowledge to build a
canoe an example you brought up because
there's a possibly no local economic
incentive for anyone to figure out or
learn how to build a canoe you have to
support yourself while you're pursuing
knowledge okay economic incentive to
have knowledge or even an island if
people are not incentivized to produce
knowledge but they have a secured
existence that allows them to pursue
knowledge some of them will pursue
knowledge for personal reasons
so you do need the economic niche and
the social niche is like well if
everyone is saying that this kind of
knowledge is pointless why are you going
into canoe making the canoe is fine the
canoe will be fine for the next hundred
years that does not encourage young
minds especially young bright minds to
go and figure out how to make the canoe
how to innovate on the canoe and then if
they did innovate on the canoe like was
this worth their time maybe maybe not
my example would be AI making cars
autonomous cars are AI making cell
phones and computers and then all of a
sudden humans don't know how to make
them after a couple generations I think
this is more similar than you might
think right if I go touch again on this
example that it went very deep
into earlier the Romans didn't know how
to train good soldiers anymore yeah
Romans imagined the Roman Empire didn't
know how to make good soldiers anymore
now in the ideal world maybe we don't
need soldiers right after you know the
dark villain has been banished there's
no need for an enemy but for a state in
that period even today you need to know
how to make soldiers right and this is a
training regiment these are highly
organized institutions like the Legion
you know a Roman legion would march 3040
miles and then they would build a fort
every day you just build a fort to sleep
in yeah yeah
think of the logistics challenges of
that right yeah and let's just hone in
how advanced this is most Roman soldiers
died in combat for centuries after this
most soldiers died of disease in other
words the Romans have such good
sanitation most of their soldiers make
it to the battlefield alive they don't
you know die of dysentery or whatever
this has only reached in the later 18th
century so there's this institutional
knowledge of how to do sanitation
logistics training how to manufacture
weapons at scale cheaply like iron
swords all of these can exist and be
implemented in people who don't know how
to build such systems remember when we
talked about bureaucracies earlier about
how there exist things that are written
for people and things that are written
for rules it's possible to have a
bureaucracy a system where everyone
knows their local rules and they know
how to write the right document so the
document makes its way up the office to
the manager but no one knows how the
whole thing works yeah no one individual
in it and if no one individual or small
group of people can get together and say
you know this do we at the DMV are we
like really on board with doing what
we're doing or are we just following the
rules and kind of don't care and don't
know like the tax code as well I know
yeah and I do pick the example of the
DMV because it's like the want something
everyone's experienced right everyone's
experienced a machine a bureaucratic
machine that treats you away another
human being never would write another
human being can be vindictive or petty
but you can reason with them you can
talk to them you can relate to them okay
you can't relate to the DMV reason you
can't reason with the DNA
either so imagine if all of society were
just made up of these large unreasonably
no machines horrible I think we're
pretty close to that